what's up welcome to another episode of
get close
i am geo and i'm bart
and excuse bart if you're listening to
our podcast right now because he's
wearing a tracksuit
so there's going to be a lot of
that happening
yeah and then also excuse me if you're
watching
uh our podcast i didn't iron my pants
and i'm very well aware of it how do you
iron those are so big
what do you mean i feel like an iron do
you know how an iron works yeah but i
feel like those type of parents not
oppressed you're not supposed to iron
because they're supposed to be big and
wavy yeah but there's cr there's a bunch
of creases everywhere oh i didn't even
notice until you pointed them out
what do your eyes see i think it's so
interesting what males and females pay
attention
to i think girls have dumb vision
all right [ __ ] explain before
things go sour
um i think girls pay attention to all
the dumb stuff
okay [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what do you mean
i mean like you know like there's all
the smart stuff that you should focus on
i'm gonna [ __ ] wrap you in that bag
suit you're wearing you know what i'm
talking about all the smart stuff should
focus on girls don't focus on that okay
so what are some smart things guys focus
on obviously not the [ __ ] toilet bowl
all the stuff that matters so what
matters
life
give me an example smartypants like when
we're vlogging for example right uh-huh
i'm trying to capture the moment you're
like oh my god
that's my best does it look good oh my
god how come you didn't tell me there's
a piece of chocolate stuck to the side
the whole time
okay you know i don't care about that
and i'm like uh that's real life and
people like vlogs that are in real life
why are you talking all kinds of [ __ ]
right now like make believe why are you
talking all kinds of [ __ ] with your
stupid big ass head wearing headphones
you told me to give an example i wasn't
trying to talk [ __ ] that is talking [ __ ]
because you're you're you're putting out
lies well don't ask me for examples and
i won't give you the truth okay so
that's how this podcast can go down huh
guys versus girls [ __ ] no you brought it
there no i didn't all i said was how do
you what are your eyes it's so
interesting how girls and guys see
different things
everybody's very interesting you know
what i said you know what i said you're
already talking [ __ ] now you know what i
said i said i agree
no you said and i was like yeah and to
further prove my point i'm like yeah i
agree and girls look at this and guys
okay look at me it's not this and that
you're like girls are stupid boys are
not so i technically got your back
no not technically got my blood because
you didn't definitely doesn't show the
[ __ ] gums on all my teeth
i like how we're like four years old i
hear me and tyka will [ __ ] argue the
same way who you and taika yeah that's
cute yeah because he's a child and i act
like a child is that what you want to
hear does that make you happy no so what
do you want to talk about today i don't
know whatever you wanted to talk about
i'm just kidding
but no really i want to know what you
see so what were you looking at when you
didn't look at my pants being all
creased
well like as any smart person would i'm
gonna i'm gonna walk out and you're
gonna do this by yourself walk out
don't walk out baby
what do you walk out for
no no don't do that
why do you hate me i love you so much
i was looking at your freaking low bar
marks on the back on your back i like
how you turned around so you could show
me when your attractive low bar marks
hey i trained dude those bursted blood
vessels next to the armpits hey you only
get those when you train hard true all
right if you're lala gagging in the
[ __ ] gym and going half-assed you're
not getting the [ __ ] true that's true so
[ __ ] off your train hard but what i see
is those pants are so big and loud like
tiny wrinkles i'm not going to be able
to see it
you know your outfit is so like
eccentric
you're not going to be able to know
centric yeah you're not able to notice
these you mean eccentric like it's very
unique it's very like pow in your face
eccentric though
what do you mean
it's eccentric yeah
oh [ __ ]
what are you asking
go ahead i don't know i think you were
trying to diss me again i'm just so on
guard right no it just seems like you
keep wanting to prove the point that
girls are dumb or something
you asked essentially three times
fine i think this is you emphasize the e
it's usually like eccentric so you say
trick well eccentric but i just you just
said eccentric stuff like
what is going on i'm just talking i'm
just i'm just italian you know i got i
got lots of lots of feelings you just
say you're italian yeah i'm got a lot of
feelings i gotta get out so i emphasize
certain words
you know what i mean certain words i
emphasize okay what other [ __ ] do you
want to talk about how about these nuts
huh you know like that like i just like
why do you want to say nuts you don't
have to say nuts but it's feeling about
these nuts you know what i mean yeah
you're saying it the same way but you'd
be like nuts
so i wanted
me some say baloney
[Music]
you're so stupid i hope you know that i
am
okay you do know that you acknowledge it
i know how stupid i am and i'm proud of
it
that's one thing i actually wanted to
talk about today what
how stupid i
am oh you're just so confident as a
person really
you don't think you're confident
well i don't know
i think that's one thing that like um a
lot of people search for
confidence why aren't you sitting like
that you're throwing me off what am i
saying you look like a turtle yeah i'm
paying attention i'm trying to like you
have headphones [ __ ]
suffocating your ears why do you need to
lean your head all right maybe i forgot
i had a monster just trying to listen
you're a [ __ ] mess i know and by you
i think we're a mess why are we
i don't know you were just talking all
kinds of [ __ ] to me so now i just feel
defeated oh good so keep going
yeah that's what i wanted to talk about
where do you get this confidence from
because you shouldn't have it really at
all how come why should you have this
confidence you're flawed as [ __ ] what's
so flawed about me everything literally
everything you name it i'll sh i'll tell
you the flop
my flat feet
yo
yo
that's a flaw
yeah i'm confident about them yeah
that's what i want to talk about doesn't
get flatter than that
that's true you got pancake feet
so what and that's what i want to talk
about good talk yeah how did you learn
to love it because they're really weird
did you always love your flat feet no i
hate them
no one athletic has flat feet and i hate
them i wish i was more athletic this is
so
frustrating why is it frustrating
because i feel like i'm dealing with a
child at this moment and then i'm
getting sucked into the childhood yeah
and then now i'm becoming a child and
i'm getting frustrated at myself for
like
getting trapped by your [ __ ] evil
ways oh my evil what are you talking
about no really do you really hate your
flat feet
i wish they weren't so flat of course
but then you said you love them
what do you mean
i don't know how else to say well i love
them because they're mine but i hate
that they're flat right so what
what
mechanism is behind you learning to love
them because you're yours
well so they're mine and there's nothing
i can do to change it
so i can live life hating them like
truly hating them a lot of people could
find ways to change it
and i have
to
how did you change it what did you
change by like lifting weights playing
more sports being more athletic
but they didn't change they didn't but
what i'm able to do with them
is i could probably do a lot more with
these flat ass feet than a lot of people
could do with the perfect arches
true
very true and i would agree yeah um
where does that come from though
was this something that
you know you were feeling bad about or
people made fun of you and you're like
nah that ain't it no i don't mean
specifically your feet obviously we're
talking about your feet of course but
it's more of a general statement because
you really do
live your life on this like
um
different wavelength who me i who the
[ __ ] the bear dude this guy right here
i'm talking to him excuse me can you
please stop interrupting i want to know
how this bear over here is so confident
with his [ __ ] flat feet his feet's
flat too they're pretty flat actually
he's got more of an arch than he does
of course you what are you talking about
what wavelength do i live life at
you you i think that was one of the
things that attracted me to you so much
your confidence you just have this like
this energy to you where it's like you
have this big dick energy really
bro are you fishing for compliments at
this time i love compliments
i give up
i don't want to talk to you anymore why
i don't want to talk to you anymore you
you keep going
no i'm talking to you go go
you go
you you think it's so funny let's see
what else you got that's it i'm done
awesome me too
i'm just listening to whatever you have
to say you're not because i'm asking you
questions okay what's the last question
you asked so you're not listening to
whatever i have to say i thought i was
if you knew how badly i want to punch
you right now
why give me kiss then no what
go
what was the question again this is the
worst podcast ever by the way
i could picture people
sitting in traffic going this is awesome
yeah because you guys could feel like
we're not the only ones that fight in
this world this is so annoying fine i'm
really trying to have a productive
session me too what's what's the
question what do you mean me too me too
on the same page
what's your question
i don't answer it hold on my my heart's
about to [ __ ] beat out of my chest
okay and not in a good way are you good
now no okay i feel it in my throat now
okay
then take a deep breath there we go and
then swallow it back down
okay so
you're very confident person
you know what your
your gifts are
you understand your shortcomings but you
don't let those shortcomings ever define
you
that takes a level of confidence
self-awareness whatever
where does that come from
um
i don't know where it came from
okay what's your first memory of having
[ __ ] like that
i do have my first
memory
of having a strength
actually you know what i think it was in
maybe in second grade
so i think up until second grade i was
i mean most kids are you're pretty
oblivious of your physical attributes
what you're capable of your athletic
ability right everyone's kind of the
same you're just doing stuff
and i remember in second grade is when
we started running
and we started doing pull-ups
for like measuring you know like do you
remember like in elementary school they
have pe where you see like how far you
can stretch and there's that ruler thing
that you put your feet up to yeah like
just like those standardized like
physical tests
and i remember
i i was running with my class
and
i was literally like either the last one
or second to last one and i tried hard
and i'm like oh [ __ ] that must be like
this asthma thing i'm just not good at
running or i just feel like man how come
these guys could run so hard it seems so
effortless because like we're you're
running laps right and then like the
fastest runner will like lap us i'm like
holy crap this guy's like on his third
lap i'm only on my second one
and then so i'd be like oh man that's
like people are just better than me at
that
but then when we did the pull-up test i
got the first one in the class
i did five
and as a seven-year-old kid
and then most kids are just like
bent arms
you know they could barely come their
way up and then the athletic specimen
um in our class who looked like he
flunked four grades
cause he was just [ __ ] huge like from
my obviously he didn't dunk because he
was only in second grade
but from my perspective when we played
basketball this guy might as well have
been doing 360 dunks yeah because that's
what it felt like
you're also a shrimp as a kid right yeah
and he was only able to do like four or
five
so all of a sudden i was like everyone's
like whoa
like bart did as much as matt and i was
like holy crap that's crazy
and then so i'm just like why why am i
good at pull-ups that's what i started
thinking about you know
and then i started like kind of watching
the way that i played
on the playground and i really liked
monkey bars
so i just think just all the hanging
around and like going around and
probably all the time i'm ejaculating on
the poles and stuff it really helped
like my pull-up game
what do you mean you're ejaculating on
the [ __ ] poles what are you talking
about remember when i told you that also
in first grade is when i found out if i
climbed a pole to the top
that i would bust these like
little nuts that i even know about how
old are you
um like six
and then it would just i just knew i
loved climbing pulse i knew when i got
to the top i was gonna feel the
sensation in my dick and it felt good
so to always climb poles like every
recess
you were busting little baby nuts yeah
okay and so probably that a combination
of pole climbing and then also monkey
bars it got my uh pull-up game pretty
good
and that was something that made me
proud of myself
you know
yeah so i think maybe that was probably
my earliest
my earliest memory or thought that
i'm different that there's
you have what you're good at and what
you're not good at
and that
you're how good those things become on
both ends is in your control yeah
and i knew that like if i started
running that's really [ __ ] complex at
[ __ ]
six seven years old maybe i just studied
a lot or i was just naturally observant
but i would just see kids crazy that
would like go up and like
oh
like that right are you already
practicing kung fu at this point at this
point uh yeah i just started
oh so yeah you wouldn't even be able to
tie those two things together yet yeah
but i would just see kids like
and just give up and like oh
i'll never be good at this yeah and then
i look at them and i'm like you're
literally sitting on the bench this
whole play like of course you're gonna
be good at that
you know
versus there's kids like you see kids
that um you know how like in elementary
school like for halloween people come in
and they're like football uniform or
basketball because they play league
and then those are the same kids and
recess smashing on everyone
oh they do extra they do extra things
that i don't do or that the school
doesn't do and i'm like no wonder
they're good like the kids that come in
with like let's say it's soccer day for
pe and they come in with like shin pads
and you're like i don't have shin pads
and other ones are like bouncing the
ball like with one foot and they're like
i definitely don't know how to do that
because i can't even hold my hands
and then you just start to kind of put
those two together and i think
um that's when i started to learn that
you can
uh increase or decrease what you're good
at increase and decrease what you suck
at
but most importantly
the feeling i got from it was so
important like the feeling of doing the
most pull-ups in class
and then going
wow this is really cool what not knowing
that that feeling is called confidence
what was the feeling uh um
what was this wow was it because people
were cheering you on or the fact that
you did it the the fact that i was the
best in the class no one can do what i
can do
that feeling i was like i don't know
what this feeling is i'm like whoa
i'm like wow that guy tried his hardest
and he couldn't do it that guy tried his
hardest he couldn't do it
only that guy
the guy who flunked four grades could do
it you know and i'm like that's crazy
what about prior to that like you would
say your mom was always so proud of one
being chinese but she would like instill
a lot of like
um
confident talking you
i never
uh it just felt like lecture uh so i
never really like resonated powering
yeah it never was empowering or writing
it's more so like this is what you
should be doing and you're not doing it
yeah cause you're trying to tell me like
chinese the best it's the culture like
look at these warriors then i'm like why
the [ __ ] are they getting their asses
kicked by all these japanese karate guys
in
you know i'm like if chinese kung fu is
so good why do they get their asses
asked us what by all these [ __ ]
japanese karate guys i'm like obviously
these guys are [ __ ]
and my mom's like look at bruce lee i'm
like yeah there's only one
i'm like there's like 10
japanese karate guys they'll kick these
other 10 kung fu guys asses
you know yeah so then going back to um
second grade you feel like tight are you
like addicted now at that point going
yeah i just understood that i was better
and i just understood that if i kept
hanging around i would maintain it
that's crazy and i knew if i stopped
hanging around i would lose it because
you could literally feel it how
how i could do that you could just feel
it like like let's say one week i played
way more handball and i go try to do
pull-ups again oh man i only got four i
got five last time and then i'm like
this week i'm gonna hang around on the
monkey bars again and then i'm go and
then i'm like oh wow i got five again
that's so interesting how like much you
paid attention yeah he's doing like
little experiments i didn't pay
attention to any of that [ __ ] what are
you paying attention to
i don't even remember second grade
i don't know maybe getting in trouble
maybe i was a lonely kid without
imagination or something but like
um i just wanted to play all the time i
think i was a lonely kid and that's
probably why i did so many experiments
like the days that i was like in like
daycare like after school
like i would pull out like all like six
handballs and i would hit slices with
all of them and i found out which ones
that had the perfect amount of air for
the sickest slices
oh my god like that's how much i was
experimenting and playing around and
mess around
and then so like when we play like
handball with people i'll be like start
touching the ball as soon as i touch the
ball i'm like oh you're dead man
or if i got a ball that's extra bouncing
i'll have a different game plan for this
ball
like i would just know i'm like this one
this is the ball i'm gonna make you run
this one bounces like crazy so i'm gonna
hit this way go that make it run all the
way that way when you follow it this way
i'm gonna hit it that way you're gonna
have to run all the way that way
and then once you catch up to my game
and start faking and then just do the
you know when they go ah let's go yeah i
[ __ ] hated that yeah you're all the
way back there you're like setting up
for it you're like no
[Music]
and like the super flat balls i knew i
could hit the slicey where it comes hits
the wall and then as soon as it hits the
wall it just only rolls so you're done
excuse me sir it's called a slider a
slider
what are slices whoa little babies say
slices they're sliders okay sorry
because they slide all right find
sliders whatever it is
i'll kill you in it yeah you did okay
exactly is that what you wanted to hear
but yeah
but that's when i that's what i
like
this like you're asking me a question
about confidence you're trying to school
me on sliders
yeah so fine yeah that's when i first
found out you can like kind of control
the things that you want you know and i
think growing up
i started to realize that more and more
and then i think just knowing that you
can't change like obviously i want to be
taller like anyone that likes sports
wants to be taller because you're just
more athletic right
um you want to be taller you want to
jump higher
but you just aren't given those things
so you you the best thing is to do is
like
try to
master the things you can control
and how can you
improve
the things that you can control
and i think by doing that you get this
feeling called confidence
that's probably what you sense
yeah cause like um
i mean the fact that you were able to
see your shortcomings and find ways if
they can change to change and improve it
and if not then going all right well how
can i use what i got
for my advantage
whereas most people would be like
oh man
that sucks
the end
i think everyone has a magical power
um i just think
it's up to the person to discover it
and if you don't try a lot of things in
your life then you're doing a disservice
to yourself because you'll never find it
because you've never looked
um
what what are some magical powers that
you think people possess
rhythm music creativity writing
literally all the channels of the world
right every every occupation that the
world needs
or even any guinness world book of
records like how does a person
know they can walk on a string the
longest
they tried it true you know they
literally tried it right they attached a
rope from one tree to a tree
and then they walked and oh i could do
that i could do that with the
balance beam can i do it without a pole
yeah can i go from this cliff to that
cliff you know everything people tried
like even like houdini like can i
survive
in a barrel off of niagara falls it's
just people exploring and just trying
[ __ ] yeah and i think most people don't
try things so they never know what their
magical power is
that's so true
that really is true
big kidney
no that's true
um
and then i think the confidence comes so
i think the first step is
you have to try a lot
from trying a lot you find out what
you're good at and what you suck at
and then the second layer is the things
that you're good at you do a little bit
more of those
and when you get a little bit better
you're like i'm really good at these
things
and then you try even more things to see
if there's more things you're good at
because it's just a numbers game the
more things you try you're going to find
out you're better at more things
you know like oh wait actually i'm not
just good at connect four i'm really
good at the rubik's cube
oh i'm not just good at rubik's cube i'm
actually really good at yo-yos or
whatever you know you just can you just
start adding adding more things and then
the things that you don't do good at
you just kind of throw them away and
then now you kind of have like
a bag full of skills and i think you end
up being pretty confident because you're
like yeah i'm like i'm i'm pretty good
at a couple like quite a few things
yeah yeah i mean i'm pretty good at
quite a few things and i don't know if i
possess the same confidence that you do
you know because there's a lot of things
where you're like you're really [ __ ]
good at that and i'm always going like
uh you're just saying that you know what
i mean so i don't know if that's
if that's also are you did you earn what
you're good at
because that's the main thing you have
to earn it
i think so
like look like saying um
well
maybe not then
or maybe i don't feel like i have like
what maybe i have maybe i don't feel
like i have so like just being artistic
right i think that just comes to me
naturally so i don't think i really
appreciate it i think i've um
like growing up i was able to pick
things up fairly quickly
and i think that in itself wasn't very
stimulating so then i would just drop it
well you probably never competed in it
have you entered into a competition
no
see so i don't think you really earned
it unless it was dance then yeah you
earned your positions yeah so they did
so
did you do a competition though
no
steve i think that's that stuff's really
important because when you earn it yeah
and then you're like oh wait i'm
actually better than people at this yeah
and you see the effort that other people
put in
you you're like
okay like it's it's a confidence that's
not like
you know like some people they're like i
can do the splats
and then they're like but they're not
they don't have any confidence because
they're just born like that you know
versus the guy yeah versus the guy
that's like
practicing the splits all the time
and then so even though they can do the
same thing that other guy is extremely
confident with it because it took them
four years to get there true you know
yeah and they probably know it way
better than you yeah kind of like you or
you were like oh i started picking up on
these patterns and i realized that you
can lose it as much as you can
you know have it grow yeah so he's
really confident in it
damn so the confidence it's it needs to
be work done by you for you to earn your
confidence no one can give you
confidence but yourself by yourself
earning it yeah 100
um and i do have i do have confidence
but i feel like i don't um
have your level of confidence and i want
your level of [ __ ] confidence what's
what's my level of confidence you don't
give a [ __ ] about anybody
is that confidence
or is that
being a psychopath no because you don't
give a [ __ ] about what anyone has to say
maybe other than me
i think i can [ __ ] destroy you if i
wanted to probably
yeah but other than what are some things
that i don't care about what other
people have to say
the way you look
what about the way i look what do i look
like
just kidding
i'm trying to get you back for the
beginning of this goddamn segment dude
man i thought you forgot about it never
i'm petty as [ __ ] that's definitely a
sign of low confidence absolutely
no but it really doesn't seem like
you're bothered by much or i guess maybe
what you give a [ __ ] about is um
not as trivial
because i think you would give a [ __ ]
about if someone called you dumb nah
you don't think you're dumb i don't i
wouldn't care if they called me that
but i think you would care if you
thought you were dumb
yeah
yeah so that's what i mean you do give a
[ __ ] about a lot of things
yeah um but i'm saying so i think when i
asked that question too it's um it's
pretty trivial things that of course you
shouldn't give a [ __ ] about but you do
give a [ __ ] about a lot it sounds like
it could be a
a balance of confidence and also ego
because
um like the things that i'm confident at
and the things that i care about
i think i try to base them on things
that matter
so if someone called me dumb
i'm like
i can provide for my family and have a
really good time with my family
that doesn't bother me at all
you know so even like a lot of the stuff
that i see like on the you know
instagram feed or news and they're like
can you believe that comedian like
called asians this what do you think i'm
so [ __ ] enraged
i'm like that to me is actually a clear
sign of that comedian's ignorance one
his ignorance
two
um his inability to tell a good joke
but
produces no feelings here
because it's my family and my family
life is good
yeah and what he's saying does not
resonate with me
yeah you know
so i think it's probably a combination
of those two
yeah
damn it's really good
yeah as i hear you talking about all
this stuff um
it really puts back in front of my face
how badly i want to train in jiu-jitsu
really yeah why
because i think jiu-jitsu um is gonna
put together all the stuff that one i
naturally already
possessed right like being creative
um being athletic
like i didn't really have to earn it
because you know
i was just gifted you know the ability
to
have the height have you know be
athletic uh be creative like this is
these are just genes that were passed
down to me
right
um
so like now having to put that
to the test in jiu jitsu which is one of
the things that you call the deep water
sports where like you're getting
suffocated and there's split decisions
that need to be made and you have to
earn every single move because any any
time you move there's a counter move to
that and like you're getting challenged
um you're getting frustrated because
it's like [ __ ] you know like you're
going to be good at you're going to be
able to beat certain people but then
other people are going to be right at
your level and that's the one that's
going to challenge you the most and
there's going to be people that are way
better than you and that's you're going
to try to catch up to them but i think
like
getting put in that position i think is
um is gonna be so confidence boosting to
me
and the fact that i'll be able to
[ __ ]
grapple you know
like i think it's it's gonna it's gonna
elevate a lot of
um
my confidence i think so i think you
know like a lot of fighters
they don't really get hurt by words like
true words i'm not talking about press
conference we're like they're selling
the fight so they're talking [ __ ] or
whatever you know we're like it seems
like they're getting riled each other up
a lot of that it's just they want to
sell seats yes this seat is theater
right it's marketing it's entertainment
but like a lot of the fighters like
um like in real life in real life
they can care less because they're like
okay they're like this is scene one at
the end of this movie if i wanted to i'm
whipping your ass
i can take your life so in the beginning
if you're just gonna talk a bunch of
[ __ ] i don't really care right
versus when you see um
like all the like the karen type videos
or like the chad type videos that you
see we got a gun it's all puffed up
whatever yeah yeah and he's getting
affected by words it's usually the guys
that have never been in a fight before
yeah so they don't have confidence and
it's it's it's actually an overconfident
display you know they're trying to
peacock
to
hope that you don't [ __ ] yeah and
they don't even they probably don't even
know that they probably really think
they're badass
and um but it's their lack of experience
that's blinding them because they've
never been tested and then so the people
that have been tested that have been
through thousands of like
matches and roles and stuff just through
their 10 years of training they know how
it's going to go down so they're just
like oh it's fine this guy's he's just
drunk he's tripping i'ma leave him alone
you know yeah versus the other guys what
would you say about my what would you
say it's because he hasn't rolled the
dice out many times so each time he
rolls a dice matters so much you know
yeah yeah
that's so true
i know usually if someone doesn't uh get
riled up like that it's like oh [ __ ]
what are they capable of
and i like that
i like that when i go to tech school
because um
when his class is ending the bigger kids
are coming in and then after the big
kids then it's the adult class so then
we get to get to school what did i say
taka's school oh jiu-jitsu that's all i
was picturing i was like oh yeah the big
kids do come in yeah you're right and
adults come in i'm like wait that school
takes adults too sorry his jiu-jitsu
school
uh and then you see these people walking
in and they're they're so like
unassuming yeah like it looks like this
guy one of the guys that walked in it
just looked like
he he's like like i don't know he works
i don't know like he just probably
builds legos all day or something like
he just doesn't look physically
threatening yeah you know he just looks
like he has soft hands do you know what
i mean yeah you know soft a lot of them
a lot of them look at them
and then you're like
man
i would have said i'll whip all over
your asses except i've been in this
class and i'll get my ass we'll buy all
of them in seconds yeah
yeah so there is this level of respect
too that's
that's like earned and obviously like
given yeah um that you're like oh [ __ ]
like i i see them walk in and i'm like
that's tight like i'm not i'm not
thinking anything what i've noticed uh
the two biggest confidence boosters
is fitness
and combat sports
giving fitness household fitness so like
i think fitness what i love about
fitness
is that
it starts with one of the purest
forms of troubleshooting
you know where you look at yourself in
the mirror a deep honest look which
already
majority of people never have a deep
honest look with themselves in the
mirror right but a deep honest look in
the mirror
objectively in going
what don't i like about my body
oh my maybe my shoulders look small
or like um oh man i'm kind of like lots
of flab in this area so you take your
your like issues that you have
and
you create a program that strategizes
on taking care of those issues
and
then you fix them
and you repeat that over and over so
you're exercising this muscle of
constantly assessing
honest planning
honest reflection planning
strategizing
completing so you really build this
confidence that not only is internal
external because you can see it you know
someone that's been lifting for five
years you just look at them and you're
like oh this guy has
tons of muscle on his upper back like
that doesn't come from
sitting one month yeah or even just
doing so there's that part of it so that
person has the must that like has
trained constantly
and fixing problems like that's
like bodybuilding the biggest thing that
their people are good at are
training how to fix problems
and strategizing then the combat sports
element i think when when your
worst case scenario is not that bad
you're like what else
is gonna be crazy you know yeah yeah
like all obviously all of our worst case
scenarios worst worst worst case
scenario is family members dying or
whatever nothing we can control about
that second worst case scenario is
getting our asses beat killed whatever
you know our survivability and if
someone is like
if 900 assailants came to me
pretty much all of them are gonna end up
in a hospital they just walk around
they're they're now the apex predator of
this world so the way a lion walks
around is way different than like a
gazelle you know the gazelles
[ __ ] you know but the line is just
like the lion can walk up straight up to
an alligator and go what's up the lion
looks at us and we're supposed to be the
apex they look at us and they're like oh
i'ma eat your ass up yeah so i think
that i think those two are super um
are super confidence builders
i like that yeah so maybe that's what
i'm missing that's why i feel like more
and more i'm like god i can't wait to
free up my schedule so that i can uh
devote more time i've been telling you
for like 15 years
yeah but it needed to come for me yeah
that's true it can't really like even
with fitness it has to come from the
person yeah it does because if they
don't want to if they don't want to do
it then it's not going to get done
if they don't have the right reasons to
do it's not going to get that
yeah
and i've always told myself i've had
this like
limiting belief if you will that like i
don't that you know uh i don't like
contact sports and um what was the other
one uh
claustrophobic yeah i'm claustrophobic
but i think we're all slightly
claustrophobic
but i think these are just really
convenient convenient excuses for me to
like
not grow from those things the stuff you
don't like you got to do the most
i know dude the hands down that's the
reason why i signed up to do jumpscares
and that's actually a [ __ ] confidence
booster in it of itself yeah because you
get comfortable with what's
uncomfortable yeah
what did you say you that's why you
that's why when i when i joined my unit
in the marine corps and i found out that
it's an airborne unit i was one of the
first people to uh sign up for jump
school why come scare the heights
i'm like well [ __ ] i might as well
learn how to jump out of airplanes such
a little [ __ ] about it
and i took uh they have this thing
called airborne pfd which is before they
send you off you have to qualify and i
took that thing like two or three times
i passed every single time to make sure
because uh the jump school is actually
an army school and you know like the
eagles that marines have they're like
they're [ __ ] [ __ ] so i'm never
every marine we ever sent to army school
they're gonna [ __ ] crush it so
whatever their army requirements
requirements are like we do double
we do double n boots and utes which is
like boots and what utes like in
utilities
when when they run theirs in regular
shoes and like running shorts
we're like aren't my units like nah if
you're gonna do it you're gonna be doing
boots which is even heavier you're
running in boots and pants
pretty much boots
yeah
that's pretty [ __ ] badass but i like
that stuff because then um
or else you're always gonna let that
thing own you you know i know and i hate
it like i hate being owned by stuff same
dude
same i hate it
and that's why i also think we're gonna
love scuba diving
you're gonna [ __ ] love it
one step at a time buddy i like scuba
diving too because so i'm a really good
swimmer right so that part is not the
confidence part the part i mean that's
not the part that like gets to me the
part about scuba that gets to me is the
breathing part because as you know i
have asthma my whole life and even when
we do like our little hot tub like
breath holding test you always smash me
oh i [ __ ] murder murder me so i know
i'm not good with holding my breath and
i'm not good with breath management
whatsoever
so i like being in that environment
where like when your heart rate is up
and you're like 50 feet under you gotta
like calm yourself down
i'm just breathing through pretty much a
straw you know like
you're just getting comfortable there
and even though i know
i'll never be like the next guy where if
you take my respirator out this guy
could survive for like two minutes i
could probably only survive for 50
seconds the fact that i'm exercising
within that 50 second time frame
i'm becoming a better strategizer
for what my weaknesses are yeah so
someone that can hold their breath for
two minutes
their evacuation strategy is based off
two minutes right like if my [ __ ] breaks
oh i gotta do this for mine i'm always
gonna stay within the 50 seconds and
then so that might actually make my
evacuation strategy more efficient than
his yeah based off my weakness
so some people might view weaknesses
as something to hold you back but in
this case i i am able to make my
weakness something that pushes me
forward yeah yeah yeah i'm trying to
adopt that more and more for sure i've
always
not always but i think i've operated
that way for a long time without really
recognizing that i was trying to push
my weaknesses out yeah i think he'd
embrace him
yeah absolutely and i think that's when
you feel the most accomplished too
because you're just like [ __ ] i did that
like me of yesterday was completely
afraid of it it's like overcoming a huge
mountain yeah climbing to the top you
might not be the best but the fact that
you're climbing you're just like oh [ __ ]
i'm not the same person anymore yeah it
is pretty rad and also i think strength
and weaknesses are almost a bad way of
looking at things
because it
adds an emotional attachment to it
rather than just looking for things
looking at things for how they are
you know like a just more of a almost
like a physics how would you look at
something how would your mind
process
uh
a perceived weakness right i would have
to call it weakness because i don't know
what else to call it yeah it's called
weakness um
and not have an emotion to it so for
example when it comes to boxing right
the go-to
the most obvious is oh that person has
long arms they're gonna jab your ass
away because they can hit you before you
hit them right so anyone with short arms
like man i'm at a disadvantage yeah
right so that's the emotion so that's
the weakness you would say short arms is
a weakness long arms is a strength yeah
right
um
but when i was training with my coach pj
shout outs to pj
i have short arms
but we don't see it like that you just
see it as attributes what are physical
attributes i have short arms what would
be a good style mike tyson's peekaboo
style so that way i'm always moving
bobbing and leaving and i'm making the
guy with the long arms miss all the time
so it's a
strength for the person with the long
arm because he can hit you from afar but
his weakness is once he releases that
punch it takes just as long time to get
here
so if a regular guy with a short arm
let's say theoretically speaking takes a
a second to hit you the guy with the
long arm is going to take two seconds to
hit you and two seconds back in that two
seconds me with a peekaboo style i could
be all up in you and i could hit you in
the ribs whatever stomach four times and
pop out as we've seen mike tyson do with
people with much longer arms right yeah
so instead of viewing things as what's a
strength what's a weakness just view it
as attributes yeah short arms you need
to fight inside long arms you fight
outside yeah you know and then so like
and there's that applied to all other
circumstances yeah very true
um as i have mentioned in a few podcasts
uh before this one is uh how i've just
been reading a ton yeah and one of the
things that one of the books that i was
reading was saying how like nothing in
life is ever as bad as we perceive it to
be and it's also never as good as we
perceive it to be that's true so it's
kind of going along the lines of of what
you're saying where you shouldn't view
things as strength or weaknesses you
should just view them as attributes i
think the same applies uh
with with saying like nothing's ever
that bad but it's also never that good
it's just it just is because at the end
of the day where ants on a ball spinning
through space
i know but you can't say it like that
either like all of these absolute
statements sometimes
get me a little bit frustrated because
i'm like yeah obviously no [ __ ] right
and i know it's i know it's it's made to
to change your perception of yeah it's a
bucket of cold water uh absolutely
absolutely right but like
you have to find the balance between the
two
you know what i mean because then they
also tell you like oh you have to be
very very present in this moment and not
but then it's like but you also have to
think about all this other [ __ ] yeah
it's like
that's why people just need to say the
things that matter at that moment yeah
you know so when i get too stuck and
stuff then i go oh yeah i'm just on a
ball flying through space chill out
you know
yeah because the same thing like i think
any proverb has its forwards and
backwards as it's right or wrong
everything just depends on like the use
case it's kind of like that tracksuit
you're wearing right now yeah where
there's like a light and a dark side to
everything every single thing and that's
why these things are so dope that is so
dope that's the [ __ ] ascent
collection i like it
barbell brigade.com i'm going to plug my
own [ __ ] that's a good collection
um
yeah no i i
i i
just that's just some [ __ ] we all gotta
get over
um cause like as you're talking about
your scuba experience right and you're
like you're gonna love it i'm already
doing all the oh god that's so [ __ ]
scary i already can't breathe i already
feel the cold ass water i already
imagine all of these [ __ ] creatures
that i can't see because the [ __ ]
depths of the ocean just eats up any
light source and i'm going oh my god so
i'm like perceiving and looking at all
these negative things about it and then
and then my other side my logical side
goes yeah you stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] if
somebody just threw you in the water
yeah that's probably what's gonna happen
but there's steps to this you're not
just gonna end up not it's it's not one
day you don't know anything and then the
next day they're to just throw you in
the [ __ ] ocean it's a very baby steps
gradual process you're probably going to
start in a pool where you can stand
they're probably just going to not even
before you go into the pool they're
probably just going to talk to you about
[ __ ]
i don't know how the
how the tank works
and you haven't even touched water yet
yeah you spend i think
i think you spend like the first
two days the first four hours of the two
days is in a classroom yeah just
learning about stuff then you understand
the theory and the second day of the
classroom is in a pool like you said
where it's only like four feet tall yeah
yeah i don't know i got to control my
emotions better because
um i let those run rampant sometimes and
then i can like
i can easily talk myself out of things
i've been trying to control my emotions
since i was a kid you know that
i don't know that like uh the first time
i forgot where i was at i was on top of
a building and i remember i felt that
vertical feeling like when you're scared
of heights at what feeling vertical okay
and i was like oh that's so scary what
the [ __ ] and then i would see some of my
friends be able to just walk up to the
edge of it
you know i'm like what the hell how come
they don't feel what i feel it's so
scary what the [ __ ]
and then later when we come back down
i'm playing with my friends on a curb
and i'm like oh i can walk up to the
edge of the curb no problem
i'm like oh man this is all perception
because if i could treat that building
like a curb which it physically is
literally exactly the same thing it's
not like gravity is stronger up there or
lighter up there
it's just me on a curb
then i would be able to dance around the
edge of the building like my friends did
but um it's just up to my perception
yeah so that's when i just realized i
need to train on this curb feel really
comfortable increase the curb increase
the curb increase the curve and then uh
through that when my friends uh when we
got a little bit older when we're 10 and
they're able to jump on like you know
like those six foot walls
that separate the houses then they would
be able to walk on those i was able to
walk on those now cuny which i would
like which i through my own practice has
able to overcome at least six feet of
heights dude i think you're just a
[ __ ] smart person really why i don't
know a lot of people don't operate like
that
like i consider myself a smart person i
might not be textbook smart yeah
but i think i'm pretty smart
um
like the way i'm able to perceive things
and the way i'm able to problem solve
and the way i'm able to like
um
say yes something i don't like about
myself i'm able to like really dial that
in and try to work on that and changing
it yeah um
you
are like
levels ahead of me when it comes to that
because you're t you're like perceiving
these things at such a young age
where yeah i was young when i was also
noticing these patterns and these these
attributes and just um
shortcomings or whatever for myself or
others
but like or maybe i just don't remember
that far back but i i
think i was an adolescent when that
started happening are you
really good
in spanish
like speaking spanish
no
i'm not
like how old of a person you think you
have a mastery of spanish
like a five-year-old probably
uh probably
no
maybe like two
no no no not that bad
maybe five i'll probably say five
cause i was thinking
maybe like my ability to draw parallels
came from being bilingual but then
you're also bilingual
because you know like when you have to
like
flip one concept into the other and
constantly do that maybe that has
exercised the muscle that has always
helped me like figure out parallels and
patterns all the time
i don't know
you know what i mean
because i'm really good at like but my
mandarin also isn't extremely good it's
probably like a seven or eight year old
um
but maybe growing up having to translate
for my mom all the time i don't know
because then i'm really good at
like reading body language and being
able to like
know what the hell is going on yeah you
could feel people real good yeah you
know and i'm not able to draw parallels
like that
yeah you're just probably really smart
you're just really smart
maybe yeah
you really need to write a book and [ __ ]
and like i don't know film some movies
and like put your [ __ ] out there it
can't die with you let's kill me we
gotta install this [ __ ] into taika
because you're really wise really yeah
for your age you're really wise i've
always thought you were pretty well i
got that children's book i've been
working on
oh you still you're still i still want
to work on it yeah as soon as i have
free time and work on it yeah without
the monkey and the cheese i know i know
what it's called i'm not gonna forget
what it's called yeah yeah yeah i feel
like i gotta challenge myself with a lot
more [ __ ]
right now i'm challenging myself in a
lot of our business endeavors yeah um
because this is really the first time
that
the first time in my life the first few
years that i've just been a full-blown
business owner
whereas before i was like a part-time
business owner but i was also like an
employee yeah
not an employee because i wasn't
technically an employee but i worked
under bosses aka you and joe yeah um
where it was like the safe space where i
can explore and do a lot of things but
not on my dime
you know like it wasn't on my shoulders
yeah like
yeah i'll take ownership but like at the
end of the day it's not really gonna
affect me in any sort of way yeah
whereas now 100 like every decision that
i make it doesn't matter who i'm
bouncing it off of it's still on my
shoulders a hundred percent yeah
um so really pushing myself in that
regard has been very rewarding and very
difficult and very
challenging um
and i'll continue to do that but i think
when i can have a little bit more of me
time
is when i really do want to focus on a
lot more of of the things that will
mentally and like physically challenge
me aka jiu jitsu the stuff that suck
teaches you the most about yourself
i know even the people that suck the
most and i think the people you feel and
i think the people that actually are the
most successful
that's actually what
um is the key to their success
is that every time they've hit a mistake
or a failure or a downfall
instead of being emotionally defeated
because like we said we attach emotions
to things right technically it's not a
failure or a defeat it's just it
happened or it didn't happen right and
so they take the emotion out of it and
then go okay
so why didn't it happen so they're able
to zoom in zoom in zoom in oh here's the
three problem areas fix it let's try it
again and it's a very emotionless and
like almost like laboratory experiment
on yourself and then you end up getting
better and better and better and better
and then they become successful yeah and
so they've exercised this muscle every
time something sucks they actually
welcome it what i've noticed is like oh
yeah
oh cool there's a
oh my employees are dating each other
and now there's a conflict of interest
and then they're like oh that's cool
that's a hr scenario i've never had
before this is pretty cool i'm glad it's
here because now i'll know what to do
for next time versus i think a newer
business owner or how i would react to
be like what the [ __ ] is going on this
good [ __ ] hr nightmare oh jesus
you know yeah versus i think the people
that are seasoned they stay they welcome
it like yeah like
like poke holes in everything because
then once you poke these holes i know
where this boat is weak and it's sealed
up and then it'll be ready to go versus
most people or even including myself but
don't poke holes because i don't know
how i'm gonna float for
i know
cause it's comfortable and we don't like
to feel uncomfortable you know comfy
right now don't poke nothing i know i
know but that's when we all grow the
most when shit's uncomfortable yeah one
thing i was listening to uh bj penn and
what i liked about what he said is he
says when it comes to training
he said it's really hard to have an ego
and the ego will be the death of you
because he goes for example imagine you
coming to fight camp
and you don't know [ __ ] about blocking
or checking leg kicks right you're like
no i'm good
i gotta trade i gotta train that cool
uh come here dude spar leg kicks only
you're gonna get lit the [ __ ] up you
know so your legs get [ __ ] tore up so
like when it comes to training and
fighting it's like when when they go in
they they can't wait to be extremely
humble and go you know what i don't know
how to block a rear naked choke i don't
know how to check leg kicks please help
me because you know you're going to spar
in the next round as soon as you spawn
the next round real life happens
all those things that you had an ego and
pretend assumption that you know how to
do it's
it gets uh capitalized on you know
something oh that's really cool like to
have that
type of mentality and then because uh bj
penn was talking about how
um
why he thinks he'll be a good governor
because he's running for governor hawaii
and he goes because it's that same
type of mindset that he's applying he's
like i when people ask me what's the
difference that like that uh
how i'm gonna be a good governor he was
like it's the same that i'm applying to
fighting i don't know i don't know [ __ ]
so that's why i have a strength and
conditioning coach i have a guy that
helps me with my striking with my
grappling when it comes to politics he's
bored yeah i don't know [ __ ] so i'm not
gonna pretend like i know but i do know
what the problems are and i'll find the
right people to help me solve those
problems yeah damn that's a dope
perspective to have yeah it is most
people really put on this thing like oh
i know everything or like you know and
and because you want to you want to
protect your ego and you want to shield
from all your shortcomings but then if
you shield them you never really get
better well and you're kind of um
taught that growing up right like you
have control over everything
because that's that's a
that could be perceived as um
like
not not being in control
right like
you don't know that what do you mean how
are you gonna how's anyone gonna trust
you as a leader
well they also teach the there's no such
thing as a bad question though
it depends on who you had as who told
you that some people are like yeah there
are such things as stupid questions
because someone was like there's no such
thing as stupid question and then
there's people that are like yeah
there's a [ __ ] ton of stupid
questions i always got sent to the
principal's office after asking my
questions yeah cause they're pretty
stupid but they're pretty funny yeah
um i was reading something about like
teacher student conversation and this is
like an elementary school kid
and um he was really sad because he
didn't feel like he was brave
and then he was asking the teacher like
how are you so brave you do so many
things that like um i'm scared to do
excuse me yeah and then the teacher's
like well i'm also scared
but
when i'm scared i just have to
i just have to do the thing that i'm
scared of and that helps me be a little
bit more brave
and then you and he just kept saying
that like and then and the next time
that thing happens i'm uh to you i i
come off as brave but it was because i
already did it
you know and then he was just telling
the student like any time you're scared
to do something that's the moment that
you should do it and then that's how you
become braver and braver and braver and
braver and the kid was like whoa
and like really clicked that's literally
how i got in trouble in school
what
by practicing what that teacher taught
what doing [ __ ] that you're scared of
yeah what do you mean
so like the teacher will be teaching
about like biology or science or
something right
and then so the teacher will go does
anyone have any questions
and i'm really scared of saying
teacher how come you don't shave your
neck
that is horrible i'm gonna shave the
back of your neck
and then so i'm like you know what i'm
gonna follow my urge
and i'm gonna do what i'm scared of
like yes mr kwan quan
uh mr teacher i believe his name was mr
okamura i'm like how come you don't
shave the back of your neck are you
serious principal's office right away
but i did build confidence so later on i
was able to ask crazier and crazier
questions what was the craziest question
you've ever asked i don't remember but
there's just they're full of them to the
point where i think teachers see my name
on the like roll call and they're like
the [ __ ] nightmares here
what did that feel like that's pretty
funny
it's [ __ ] funny as a student i would
enjoy it yeah you know as a as a as a b
and below grade student i would enjoy it
like this guy is ruining my education
yeah yeah yeah
um and if you were my friend i would
love it because it's funny but all
you're doing is just distracting the
whole class i know but i was scared of
it and i faced my fears so that's really
good yeah good for you dude
i feel like as a as a student i was
probably like a michael scott you know
i'm like taking those proverbs and it's
supposed to be i don't think so at all
but i was always doing that other thing
no i don't think you were michael scott
i think you've just always been a
comedian and i'm pretty sure a bunch of
these teachers really liked you
but they [ __ ] so they liked you as a
kid that wasn't in their class
disturbing everything they're trying to
do
oh i'm pretty sure they like you and
they're like man this kid's going places
or he's really funny or like yay i'm
glad he's here but then now having to
put you in the setting that you had to
be in which is an obedient quiet member
of [ __ ] this this classroom society
you're a [ __ ] nightmare yeah you know
but maybe outside of that they were like
oh dude bart's actually really cool
or they probably [ __ ] hated yourself
there are a lot of teachers though
because so now it's very funny right
because like teachers are just humans
they're just people yeah that are given
this title but as a kid you think at
least i did um that teachers are just
far superior humans i always thought
they were just so superior so then
anytime i would see a teacher go out of
line and get like scream or get angry or
like i've seen a teacher pull a kid's
hair one time
um i'd be like
whoa they're kind of like i didn't
understand how [ __ ] bad that was
i think i saw that early on because i
was a kid that made the teachers go out
of line
and what did you see
i would just see the teachers like what
did you understand i should say
because i think originally i saw
teachers as like oh wow they're like
these like perfect humans and like
because even that's oh when they would
like [ __ ] loosen up their tiger like
oh they're humans because even that's
the way that like
uh the chinese culture reveres teachers
you know like even on the street you see
him at the supermarket
you know it's always like almost like
calling like professor like once they
earn the title of a teacher it's a very
revered occupation and that's how i grew
up
um almost like oh hey yeah hey doctor
like dr kwan like how's nice to meet you
you know it has that like
that um prestige yeah and
but then um
because i was a troublemaker
i would always see hella teachers get
emotional and out of line and scream and
do whatever with me so i was like oh man
you guys are not you guys you're not who
you say you are just you guys are just
human beings but now that i'm
older and unlike the teacher's age i'm
like man teachers go through a lot you
know they're regular people they got
marriages they could have
had a fight at home or they could have
had something go their car wouldn't
start for 30 minutes in the morning and
now they're rushing and then now they
got to put up this perfect front in
front of classes tough it is tough and
then here comes [ __ ] big-headed quan
you got big-headed quan come here
[ __ ] causing a ruckus god damn it
well if anything if they were positive
and adopted uh your level of mindset of
like hey there's no bad or good and
anything that is
perceived as bad is a lesson if they
adopted that and they had that mindset
then they would see you as like a
learning lesson that you
you showed them a [ __ ] in their armor
maybe
one of my favorite teachers of all time
i don't know and i think this is why i
probably even started scuba diving his
name is mr tarpley
shout out to where you looking
shout outs to mr tarpley
um if you're still alive
but uh
this is my medical middle school
assistant principal and there's so many
times where i got sent to the office got
suspended i was supposed to get expelled
but he always fought with me
for you for me
against the principal shout outs to uh
mr green i hate your ass and
and he always spot for me and um so like
i would get sent to the principal's
office and like let's say i'm there all
day until my mom needs to pick me up
he'll always go why are you coming my
classroom i mean you can call him in my
office
so like what is mr green doing just
giving you the [ __ ] evil eye yeah
he would just be like you're not gonna
be here for long wow how rude like
almost like a like a like a
90s villain you know
i was like this one's probably going to
be the one like that what a loser
sayonara like that like that kind of
she's a loser yeah and then mr tarpley
would bring me in like he would just
play hey just sit here until your mom
comes so because i'm like you know some
teachers come and give me dirty looks or
they didn't want me sitting on the
reception and all that people are always
going to be a mature yeah and all the
other kids would come and be like oh man
bart's at the office again so he was
just putting me in and what i love about
his office he had all these photos of
him and his son scuba diving oh and i
think that's how i always thought scuba
diving was a positive cool thing because
they would go visit shipwrecks
and and all that stuff like they would
take pictures and he would just see like
him and his son like floating in the
middle of the ocean it was so cool and
then mr tarpley was uh left-handed so he
was one of those guys that's like
literally smearing what he was writing
and like every time he's just signing
paper though still just laugh i just
couldn't even though i love them
even though i love them
i'm like i'm always like mr like have
you ever thought about like writing with
your hand like above the paper
that way you like
go nah i'm good i'm alright and then as
he's writing he's just literally
smearing it and then now when he's
talking to my mom i just see like all
like this black ink like
poor guy man
he would have excelled in like like i
don't know writing in japanese like
chinese yeah he was just like writing
all curve-handed like this
and he would just smear
my sister's left-handed so i know all
the woes of a
left-handed person it was just so funny
yeah
all right you big cuny pie who talks
[ __ ] in the beginning i was able to
[ __ ] control my emotions and not want
to punch you in the face anymore at the
end of this podcast i'm helping you grow
ah
thank you
are there any
uh last words for you no
[ __ ] hate you why do you hate me
again all right well anyway
i have grown a lot in this podcast
thanks to you for challenging me in the
beginning i did fall victim
to it and i do want to apologize for
everyone listening i'm not proud of that
first five ten minutes um but since then
i have grown
i i've you can't grow in an hour control
over my emotions and i feel good about
myself you can grow as quickly as you
let yourself
yeah
thank you confucius
um on that note thank you so much for
listening and for watching and we'll see
you next week